pour ses 50 ans le diagnostic est tombé
pascal souffre de la maladie de
parkinson
ça fait neuf ans que je sais que j'ai la
maladie mais très semblablement ça a
débuté une dizaine d'années pavant
troubles du sommeil rigidité dans ses
mouvements traits du visage qui se fige
et perte de l'odorat ont donné l alerte
j'avais un odorat extrêmement développé
et tout d'un coup plus de doha je me
suis aperçu aussi que quand je marchais
j'avais un bras qui ne balançait plus et
puis surtout les tremblements alors là
je cliquais n'importe où j'arrivais pas
à mettre la crème sur le visage enfin à
touiller la salade les difficultés du
quotidien amplifie les symptômes de la
maladie de parkinson
pascal à son échappatoire le stress
accentue les symptômes de la maladie
le bruit de l'eau le bruit de la cascade
se feront du bien
c'est le seul petit point zen imaginez
les pieds pas prêt pas peut-être des
petites branches qui craquent sentir les
odeurs et se laisser imprégner d'une
énergie de renouveau la pratique d'une
activité physique douce aide à contrôler
et l'anxiété des malades et à diminuer
leurs symptômes
lâchez les mains et puis observer
observer comment vous vous sentez elle
est arrivée bien sûr avec ses douleurs
avec ses raideurs et puis à la fin de la
séance
c'était vraiment flagrant là elle elle
tremblait plus à cet instant pascal
prend de la dopamine toutes les trois
heures elle a ce qu'on appelle des
périodes on off
quand je suis en vain de doses alors là
je vois la maladie qui a peu surgi à
grands pas et alors j'ai l'impression
d'avoir les boulets aux pieds
d'être complètement enfermé dans une
cage pascal ne se renferme pas sur elle
même elle reçoit ses amis une
préparation s'impose le to7 pas trembler
les douleurs provoquées par la maladie
peuvent modifier les rapports avec
l'entourage
la proportion de personnes atteintes de
dépression est beaucoup plus élevé avec
la maladie de parkinson que la moyenne
c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de
volonté et je suis très admirative de
voir avec sa maladie tout ce qu'elle
fait elle recule la maladie elle l'a
fait reculer l oubli même si la maladie
se rappelle à elle se confie à des
personnes attendent des mêmes maux
france parkinson propose des rencontres
pour échanger et s'informer
pascal participe aux réunions de
rambouillet à 59 ans elle est consciente
que cette maladie neurodégénérative a
bouleversé sa vie ne dit pas je ne fais
plus faire ça il faut dire aujourd'hui
j'arrive à faire face persévérante
elle profite de chaque instant au
maximum ne sachant pas de quoi demain
sera fait déterminée elle pratique la
danse en ligne depuis trois ans un
excellent exercice pour les personnes
atteintes de parkinson
la line dance ici on apprend vous avez
vu des chorégraphies avec des pas qui
font entre 32 et 64 temps par côté par
murat répéter donc pour la mémoire c'est
énorme et ça pour le cerveau je pense
que c'est vraiment important pour ces
personnes-là pascal s'est fixé un
objectif réussir entièrement sa
chorégraphie malgré la maladie est
envoyé sa performance à france parkinson